thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we bring love and
greetings from Uganda the pal of Africa
survive
I must tell you these ladies and
gentlemen the music you're about to
witness is band music okay we cannot
perform this song because
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
trying to
fight
[Applause]
ers
remote
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
loving you to the maximum all the people
from all walks of life who bring love
from Africa
welcome to Africa although not
physically but spiritually and
culturally and musically
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it's time
[Music]
[Applause]
are you feeling
all right ladies and gentlemen that was
it for this afternoon you enjoy the rest
of the day
come on man come on
ladies and gentlemen we don't take it
for granted that we are able to perform
to you we come from Uganda but our fans
are friends in Uganda can only watch us
perform on social media and they can
only watch us on Facebook when they go
through VPN because Facebook is also in
Uganda our music is banned in Uganda
because I committed the worst crime and
that is contesting
myself anyway s
[Music]
so while you are enjoying the music
I'm glad for you
[Music]
don't understand
I'm a brother and friend here his name
is Nubian Lee is the one that seconded
me when I was being
but that was a resident spent seven
months in 3
first time that we
let me perform free
dwelling
[Music]
people power because
that will not programs
[Music]
example
I just want you to know one thing
give me Justice anywhere
and a dictatorship anywhere is a threat
to a democracy
for 37 years
[Music]
illegally the president
so many of our brothers away I was away
for more than eight months just for
speaking the truth and expressing five
political views so we are not
we are not criminals when we want
Justice
we want citizens
because
[Music]
of this world
and Injustice anywhere is an injustice
name
and then you have to speak
this song
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
another baby
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
anyways
[Music]
[Applause]
everything
[Music]
for me
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
don't you ever take your freedom for
granted it's always one step away from
Extinction
here we are doing what should have been
done by our grandfathers and mothers and
we're doing it because we want to save
[Music]
all of you the people of America
like my brother say
oppression anywhere on Earth is a threat
to Freedom everywhere on Earth
for a long time dictators have been
tolerated in distant places because they
believe that it's none of their business
I want to tell you Americans the freedom
in Africa
you are part of it whether you know or
you don't know
we are responsible for each other
we find the opportunity I'll be
performing to the politicians in America
but I'm performing to people that are
more important than politicians and that
is you the taxpayers
the USA gives up to a billion dollars
every year to January
that is the money that being used
on our people
for no crime whatsoever
we know that if you push your leaders to
change the policies in Africa you can
save us we are not asking you to come
and save us we're asking you to stop
sponsoring our operation
we know
that you have the freedom that we unfold
you have the ability
to call your leaders your
representatives in Congress
[Music]
in Africa stop sponsoring military
dictators in Africa
[Music]
in Somalia and many other parts in
Africa
last year I traveled to Ukraine in the
middle of the world
I want to tell you that that happens
regularly in Africa on the 18th and 19th
on the street
yes it was condemned by the U.S but a
few months later
[Music]
we can do it all together we should be
United
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you all right
[Music]
[Applause]
every day
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
because we choose
[Applause]
you know
[Music]
everything
[Applause]
[Music]
is
gonna be fine
all right let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
understand
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
remember
me
[Applause]
[Music]
is gonna be mine
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
fun
my name is
[Music]
thank you thank you
yes we celebrate
Pride it doesn't matter whether we all
get there but at least I know some of us
will get there we did not start this we
don't have to end it we just have to
keep the hope
[Music]
wind is
thank you
[Music]
wow victory
happy birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]